this
is the 50th episode of
howie dustin
so this is the 50th episode
this is does that look good
you know what i find after 50 episodes
we cut we get it like we're smooth
rolling now
right who should we have on the 50th
episode jackie
who should we have on our 50th episode i
want a friend yeah i want somebody that
is fun yeah i i want somebody i mean the
50th is a number
were you uh good looking well look we'll
think about it somebody beautiful uh-huh
somebody
someone with really pretty feet cannot
think of who to have on the 50th episode
of howie mandel does stuff
oh we're going to come up with a guest
i think we are i'll think of someone
yeah is that it okay
no
no
let's do one more take
[Laughter]
i love it you got to keep all of this
are we rolling
let me guess don't tell me don't ruin it
for me don't ruin it i'm talking to you
heidi don't ruin it for me
okay
who no this is gonna be it's fun to
guess what
okay i'm gonna give a clue can you tell
by the voice who it is
it's hot
do you want to shoot my legs for the
50th episode of how he does stuff i
think people want to do more than shoot
your legs what kind of stuff does howie
do we will find out
what are you doing
i should have that voice but i don't
sadly
[Music]